Alex Mandel you got to check him out he
has a product out he does called
mouthguard challenge yeah he does you
know what their son and you're not even
playing just gonna show it cuz this is
your son came up with this and that is
your son on the cover of the box
yeah well he's wearing a mouth guard you
wear that mouth guard you can go get
that at Barnes & Noble yeah what's up
what what you wear the mouth guard and
what is the actual challenge do whatever
you got to do with him look you just put
it you just put it it just goes how does
it go goes like the side wins site like
this right yeah yeah Zack oh you know
are you higher well I don't want that
one does it go sideways or this way no
no you had it right
you had it right but yeah just goes yeah
you really take an interest in your
son's work well you don't know what the
hell it is you're a natural for QVC yeah
wait so what I don't understand what's
happening right now what are you doing
how is this helping your son's product
put one on and now it's done yeah how do
you do it slowly med and then and then
you what you just walk her and look like
an ass looking like an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah what's the point
oh okay and then they said Sonia diet
anything your ear is the tongue I say
one thing no that thing in your mouth
it's the only time that you finish a
sentence no I don't understand right now
is horrified they think you've had a
massive stroke
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well mouthguard challenge man you just
sold that pretty well I think I did I'm
gonna be sued by your own side I want
people to watch Thursdays 10:30 on Spike
karaoke showdown I was about to plug
let's go say bye Craig rod listen but I
want to tell you something yes if your
viewers use hash tag karaoke showdown on
their social media I'll follow them
isn't that a treat is that a real
question yes I hit a tree 10:30 on
Thursday and Spike and I'll tweet live
but everybody I want everybody to watch
it if they spike said if we get three
more viewers they might pick it up
I'm not kidding so to be able to get
REME all over dragon you're gonna watch
it
alright your hands up we got three
you